thank you so much for waiting we just
had a fire alarm and i didn't know what
to do oh hold on there's still people
walking by you want that you are such a
pro i can't believe you just ran outside
on a fire drill came back down sat down
tucked your hair behind your ears and
like okay here are my questions in south
of heaven evangeline plays annie a
terminally ill woman whose childhood
love jimmy played by jason sedakis is
released from prison after serving 12
years for armed robbery jimmy vows to
give annie the best last year of her
life but things go
so did you ever imagine that we'd have
to pick our wedding song
and my death song in the same year
evangeline has high praise for her
co-star who recently took home two emmys
for lead actor and outstanding comedy
series for the hit show ted lasso so
obviously i want to ask you about
working with jason savage are you
obsessed with ted lasso like the rest of
us okay so fellas let's go ahead and
give dan a little bit of space right now
yeah y'all don't mind showering at home
do you totally obsessed with ted lasso
i'm doing the old school tv thing and
watching every episode as it comes out
on friday you know there's so much i
want to ask you about when it comes to
this film but let's talk about your
transformation i shaved my head about a
year before i did this movie for myself
like this i just shaved my head it
wasn't for the role i spent two months
growing my hair for this movie and then
i bleached it
my kids hated it we'll bet her kids love
seeing mom as the superhero
dad are you seeing this oh get out of
there yep evangeline is set to return as
the wasp in marvel's ant-man and the
wasp quantomania in 2023. i do want to
ask you about the ant-man sequel is it
exciting to get back into that character
well it's always a little bit
nerve-racking it's like i want to honor
the character and have her be the same
character that people come to know and
love